make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and uh
make sure you guys hit the like button
if you enjoy the video
and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with judgement day and i gotta
say man this story just gets better and
better and this this issue god it is so
phenomenal this is absolutely amazing
i'm trying to figure out if we should do
this like just over the course of the
week and then like every other day just
do like a second video um or if we do
this is like a weekly thing right
because the weekly thing just it makes
it so exciting just kind of anticipate
it but i had to cover this story right
so here's the thing this story focuses
on exodus and those of you guys who have
been following the x-men mythos as we've
done it so far right jonathan hickman's
run going into jerry dugan's run and all
that kind of stuff you've seen exodus
just kind of lingering around but you've
never really seen him fight and in fact
you never really got a whole lot of
insight in the mind of exodus which kind
of sucks because actually this has been
around for a long long time right so
exodus he originally appeared way back
in 1993 with x factor issue number 92
and in fact he became a part of
magneto's acolytes when he was quote
unquote woken up by magneto in x-force
issue number 25 which i'm pretty sure
was released that same year but what's
really funny about his character though
is that despite being introduced in the
early 90s we didn't get an origin form
until black knight the one-shot story
that was told in 1996 that it picked up
off of a defender's story which
basically saw that dane whitman the
black knight and cersei of the eternals
were basically time displaced and they
ended up in the 12th century and we'll
talk about that here in a little bit but
what this initially does is it basically
picks up on kind of the origin of of
exodus i've been a duperee now this is a
smart decision to make by kieran gillen
it's a genius decision because exodus is
a character people are now aware of but
only because of his time on the quiet
council and everything going on with
jonathan hickman's run up until now um
but he's a character people don't know
the story of and a lot of people don't
know just how ridiculously overpowered
this guy is it's it's crazy how powerful
he is so the thing about this is that
benadu perry initially rose to
prominence during the crusade this
initially opens up when he's actually
out in the desert and he encounters the
phoenix force now it doesn't possess him
but he simply just meets him and it's
one of those things where it was the
first time that he actually encountered
anything that could really be referred
to as a god despite the fact that he was
fighting in the crusades up until that
point it was just some disembodied being
that exists out there in the ether right
whose word he follows and like that was
it that was really all there was but
seeing the phoenix force physically
manifest actually instilled in him a
faith but it was actually a faith
predicated on mutants now the thing
about this is he didn't know he was a
mutant at the time and we'll talk about
how we reconcile that here in a second
but what it does here is it jumps back
to krakow and it basically picks up with
everything that he's talking about and
really just like why counsel themselves
who were talking about how a war with
the eternals are coming right so this
takes place slightly before the events
of judgement day number one proper but
it's one of those things where they're
kind of like you know how do we come to
terms with this right one uh nathaniel
essex right like mr sinister he's been
kidnapped and we don't know exactly how
to cope with this like if he's been
taken by the eternals they've literally
started a conflict by basically
kidnapping one of our own how do we
respond in time without instigating a
full-scale war now on one side you have
what are basically the more level-headed
people right so emma frost to a degree
charles xavier so on and so forth on the
other side you have the warhawks like
sebastian shaw who were like no we can't
operate on the defense it's offense we
have to go and get him and then if a war
starts whatever let the chips fall where
they may right we are the mutant
population there are more of us than
there are those eternals we can take
them on but the reality here is that
sebastian shaw painfully misunderstands
just how many eternals there are and
what form those eternals take and that's
one of the things that's really being
hit on here during the judgment day
story is that the eternals are not
simply just the people that we've seen
marvel published stories about over the
course of the last however many decades
and like that's it that the eternals are
huge in number and there's a variety of
them all over the world that we simply
just didn't know about which is kind of
interesting because in a lot of ways the
judgment day event and the the whole
revelation of the eternals of marvel
comics is very much following the
inhumanity storyline and i'm sure a lot
of you guys who are aware of inhumanity
coming out of the storyline that came
out of like infinity right that story
itself which basically dealt with a
black bolt detonating the terrigen bomb
spreading the terrigen myths across the
world and then all these people who were
in humans and didn't know it suddenly
just waking up to become inhumans right
just going through pterogenesis so like
you know kamala khan and like all those
different characters it very much feels
that way to a degree except it's really
more that we're discovering the fact
that they've always been here as opposed
to the fact like they're just now coming
into existence but one of the things
that happens here and xavier is really
kind of the top guy in the quiet council
albeit unofficially they are all
technically equal in power but because
of xavier's history with the x-men he's
kind of like the number one guy sort of
everybody just kind of silently agrees
on that that that he really looks at it
from the perspective of saying okay like
the reality here is that the eternals
they hold no grudge that we know of we
expected orcas we are not prepared for
war against them but from exodus
perspective he's just kind of hitting on
this and he's like sinister's gone this
is suspicious for dozens of reasons we
should purge him from the quiet council
and it's one of those things where as he
thinks and as he analyzes he looks over
at destiny and he sees that destiny has
a kind of small twitch in her chair
which is enough for him to realize him
just having these thoughts could
potentially have a massive impact on the
future now remember it's very difficult
for destiny to predict what's going to
happen based on what somebody's thinking
or things that are supposed to happen in
the far-flung future she's very very
good at predicting on the battlefield
it's one of the reasons why when she was
part of mystique's brotherhood she was
instrumental in their ability to defeat
the x-men because literally they would
be in the heat of combat and she would
be like gambit's coming from that
direction and like they would be able to
overpower gambit before he even got
there it was just one of those things
right i might go back and cover those
older x-men stories because there's just
so many callbacks in this run and it
makes me really nostalgic for it but
what he ends up doing is actually
talking about how destiny currently sits
in the chair of apocalypse and
apocalypse is gone and then he has a
flashback to his own history and says
apocalypse is here but here is not now
and it's one of those things where he's
literally jumping to his own origin
story now this is one of the things to
to explain here right because what you
end up having is this situation where
you basically end up having cersei and
iamar garrington who essentially meet
with exodus after he becomes exodus so
to fill in these gaps here which are not
readily explained by kieran gillen and
to actually give you the origin of
exodus the way this played out is that
as part of the crusades that exodus and
i guess bennett duperry which is what
he's initially known as and eobar
gerrington are basically trying to find
what's called the tower of power now the
tower of power itself at least as it was
explained in the old black knight exodus
story it's not really a tower of power
in a literal sense it's the home of the
eternal pharaoh now what they don't know
is that it's actually the home of
apocalypse they really don't know what
they're getting into here but the way
this story played out is that it was
actually picking up off the heels of an
existing defender story where the black
knight dane whitman and cersei were
effectively time displaced and so what
it did is it led to them arriving in the
12th century when that happened the mind
or spirit or whatever you want to call
it of dane whitman entered the body of
eobar gerrington who is basically his
ancestor right he's one of the the older
black knights that existed in marvel
comics before dane whitman became the
black knight and so what that did is it
led to dane just kind of occupying the
body but not actually having control
that eobard himself had control and so
that's why if you go back and you read
that story that something seems a little
off about e of r garrington when things
first pick up and he talks about how
like he had seen a woman and like the
whole thing feels like a dream to him
but he eventually encounters cersei and
when that happens he abandons the quest
with bennet duperry who continues on his
own and so ultimately he ends up coming
across apocalypse an apocalypse puts him
through these kind of trials which even
now are not readily explained in this
particular comic at least even in just
this one the immortal x-men tie-in for
judgment day but the important thing
here is the trials were done in the
manner by which apocalypse normally
conducts trials which is to say it was
testing the mind body and spirit of
exodus to determine whether or not he
was even worthy of any enhancements
apocalypse could give him ultimately
bennett was proved worthy and in doing
so apocalypse realized that benedu perry
was a mutant he activated his ex-gene
and then amplified his powers and what
it did is it pushed exodus to becoming
an omega-level telepath and telekinetic
the guy's wildly powerful i mean this
guy has an advance like an accelerated
healing factor it's not really on the
same level as wolverine but it's a
really it's an exceedingly capable
healing factor the guy's got enhanced
longevity his telekinesis is so
fine-tuned that he can actually alter
the molecular structure of matter now
marvel's never moved that past just
surface use right they've never moved it
into the realm of him being able to like
alter matter on a universal scale
arguably he could marvel just doesn't
really do it so think of it more as like
a soft cap on his powers they just
haven't really explored that part of his
character yet but even beyond that the
guy's telepathy is on on the same level
as jean grey professor xavier those guys
he can teleport to virtually any
distance anywhere it doesn't really
matter where it is the guy's
ridiculously capable but having those
powers augmented and having his his
abilities amplified also added a caveat
and the reason why is because in this
story and this this one that we're
covering here as well as in the old
black knight exodus stories that what
happened is that as a testing initially
apocalypse instructed cersei and eobar
to kill exodus which they refused to do
he then instructed exodus to kill them
which he refused to do and in fact he
turned on apocalypse and actually ended
up fighting apocalypse and trying to
overpower him right because again exodus
being a guy who's very much who very
much follows religious convictions comes
to the realization that apocalypse is by
all standards of measurement a false god
and in fact he declares him that that
apocalypse is not the god that he
reports himself to be he's just a really
powerful guy and so when exodus turns on
apocalypse apocalypse overpowers him and
then locks him away now the biggest
issue that you had to contend with when
it came to that is in later stories
exodus just demonstrated levels of power
that were so high that it left people
asking how in the hell could apocalypse
beat this guy and so what marvel did is
they added in the caveat that his powers
are tied to his confidence if he's
surrounded by the right kind of people
or if he is if he has full confidence in
himself that exodus powers reach their
total peak and this guy is an absolute
monster when he's operating at his peak
but even when he just believes in
himself his power is more than enough to
rival apocalypse and and really even
overcome apocalypse and that's how
marvel fixed that is by saying that at
the time when he initially fought
apocalypse he wasn't entirely certain of
what he was capable of there was a
little fear when it came to apocalypse
and he didn't have the highest amount of
confidence in himself and that's how
insabon nur was able to defeat him and
so following that he was effectively
locked away now one of the things that
this does is it jumps back to the modern
era right following this kind of
flashback it jumps back to the modern
events when the eternals launch the
attack of the unimod right you're like
literally uniting their minds together
and launching a telepathic attack
against the against krakowa and the
quiet council and so as that happens of
course the telepaths themselves are able
to fend off the attack but the funny
thing here is that we're xavier and
everybody else is basically struggling
to hold their own then it's doing it
with the greatest of ease he's he's able
to hold he's able to just hold it off
right and it's just kind of like yep i
mean it's it's a thing that i'm dealing
with because while he's dealing with the
unimine he's flashing back on his own
memories which if anything this is a
testament to how powerful he is but then
following that he kind of touches back
on his own history and talks about how
he had slept for hundreds of years and
then was ultimately woken up by what he
thought was another not really a mutant
god but a kind of messiah he was woken
up by magneto now again this is in the
old x-force comics x-force number 25 and
this is when magneto arrives and
purports himself as a messiah because
this was old-school magneto or really
kind of new old-school magneto this is
during the x-men volume 2 era and that
in effect what had happened is that when
when magneto woke up exodus that exodus
ended up joining his acolytes now the
acolytes of magneto were amazing back in
the day fabian cortez and all those guys
but basically they were like people who
were just religiously devoted to magneto
they saw him as a god in a lot of ways
right the messiah who was going to bring
about the positive change that they had
been looking for which was to basically
eliminate this the you know humanity in
terms of its hatred of mutants and to
either leave mutants into a better place
which in this instance was basically
avalon or it was to eradicate the mutant
population in its entirety so the
mutants could live on earth without fear
of of humans hunting them but the thing
about this is that beneduperi came to
the realization quite quickly that
basically magneto was no really not
really a messiah or anything like that
if anything he was kind of a prophet but
much like apocalypse he was just a
mutant who was out there who was
purporting this idea that he could lead
people into a better future and so
ultimately exodus became disillusioned
and ended up walking away now of course
jumping back to the to the current
events again this leads to uh to
wolverine showing up and saying like
there's some kind of silent eternal
running around here and is killing off
the various members of the five now we
saw that during the judgment day story
if you guys recall that you literally
had that eternal uh who was killing the
members of the five and that magneto was
able to stop her before they could go on
like eradicating everybody because once
the five are gone there's no way to
resurrect anybody anymore right because
the five are the means by which people
are resurrected so there's no way to
resurrect them so that's why they're
they're really kept in the hatchery
they're kept exceedingly well protected
by the mutants in fact they're protected
more than xavier and magneto are right
it's they're like the entirety of cocoa
lives and dies by the members of the
five they almost caught hope summers and
so on and so forth and so it's a really
really cool thing because what what
exodus does is in listening to all of
this you know like emma emma frost
talking and all these guys he's like i
need to interpret the situation in a way
that i understand and so he's like i am
a knight right and i am in the desert
and this force is not the eternals that
i'm facing off against it's just a
dragon right i'm interpreting it in a
way that just makes the most sense to me
and so literally it's one of those
things where he kind of mulls over this
whole situation and then he starts
thinking about hope summers and that's
when he comes to this realization or
really just kind of gives us this
realization that he had that for the
very first time in the history of his
life he encountered what he actually
thought was a true messiah and the
person he views as an actual messiah and
it's the reason why exodus has such a
reverence towards hope summers on the
island of cocoa you've probably noticed
it as you've been reading the different
x-men comics we haven't heavily focused
on it because in all honesty i didn't
know if they were ever going to really
explore it at all but they are here
right kiran gillan is focusing on it
here and the reason for this and exodus
even says that is he says when the
scarlet witch he refers to her as the
red witch but he says when the scarlet
witch altered reality during house of m
and then set everything back and in
doing so took away 98 of the mutant
population's powers reduced the
population down to about 198 mutants
that he was one of the only mutants that
retained his abilities now different fan
bases have argued different things based
on the power of exodus that exodus was
so incredibly powerful that he
subconsciously used his own powers to
actually override the influence of the
scarlet witch so he could maintain his
own abilities again that's just total
fan speculation there's never been
anything in the comics to indicate that
was the case although it'd be amazing if
it were true but regardless he looks at
this whole thing and says like for a
time there were so few of us left i
thought we were on the brink of
destruction i thought our extinction was
imminent but the truth is that in the
main marvel universe following the
events of house of m decimation and all
that kind of stuff that's when you
basically started coming into hope
summers when hope summers popped up on
the scene you eventually got the 12
light story line and the 12 light story
line was basically hope summer's
becoming the messiah and the fact that
her birth solidified the return of the
mutant population to the main marvel
universe mutants started being born at a
higher rate right they were literally
coming back and so that's why exodus
sees hope summers as a true mutant
messiah and he takes it as a personal
mission in saying because the eternals
had launched an attack against hope and
because they almost killed hope that now
they have basically attacked what he
views as being his god right his messiah
the messiah of the mutant population and
so in response it's one of those just
it's one of these amazing things because
while they are able to overcome the
unimined this leads to the secondary
attack of the eternals which we talked
about at the end of judgment day when
you basically have these just enormous
eternals who aren't really machines they
are actually eternal beings that
basically start attacking krakowa and
these things are massive and powerful we
don't know exactly how powerful but we
know they're exceedingly powerful and
it's one of these amazing moments where
like exodus just has this insane
monologue he tells hope summers right
when home summer says we're not ready
for this right we're not ready for those
guys that's a level of power that we as
mutants are not ready for the response
of exodus is we are and i am right he
says return to safety and return the
fallen warriors to the field be an
inspiration guard the flame of mutant
life be yourself it is more than
sufficient and when she says what are
you going to do his response is their
dragon's hope what do you think i'm
going to do and he says i am the pope of
a new church like peter was long ago he
says peter was the rock upon which the
nazarene mutant built his church and he
says yes i am that rock but i am also
the rock in the hand of kane i can build
or i can destroy and no one out there
can do it on the level that i can with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end i gotta say man this
story arc just keeps getting better and
better god it's absolutely phenomenal
but we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace